billionaire owners of the company that
gave us Oxycontin have won a court
Victory protecting them from civil
lawsuits over their involvement in the
opioid business the federal appeals
court ruling allows Purdue Pharma to
complete bankruptcy restructuring and
settle thousands of legal claims against
the company members of the Sackler
family had insisted they'd be protected
from personal liability over Purdue's
manufacturing and marketing of Oxycontin
the sacklers will surrender up to 6
billion dollars of their family fortune
for addiction treatment and prevention
programs and compensation to individual
victims opioid drugs like Oxycontin are
blamed for more than half a million
deaths in the U.S this Century the
ruling may be appealed to the Supreme
Court